l'ortie est très
o o
e
dix médailles
bâle
et j'ai passé ma bulle de placement
pendant ce temps là
pour pas dire
ça devant attendre la saison
profitez conseil
il n'y a pas du verbe à dépanner des
buttes
g bon sens parce que j'ai regardé la
caméra montre là et on peut y accéder de
notre côté aussi d'accéder voilà c'est
pour ça moi je n'avais pas pris la bonne
roue
donc on a mené les consignes le départ
c'était pour pas s'affoler la montée
amour hâtivement long on a vu deux
heures donc gérard tu as la carte et de
vente
voilà il ici qui doit pas faire des
pauses de temps en temps pour attendre
ses pions montrent un peu moins vite on
va se caler tranquillement ce poisson on
arrive en haut vous remettra le temps
qu'on a besoin pour le faire donc ça va
bien se passer
pas très bien à sa place à plaisir
d'avoir réussi un grand sportif
donc quand il s'agit d'amour dénivelé
comme ça c'est mes galères comme un mois
d'août
ouais je prends ton rythme
copenhague oblige les pilotes donc j'ai
demandé à venir avance philo et après
bonn dont puma tryba dur affirme abou
relais avec un désinfectant que
l'affairé va ailleurs dans une merde on
pourrait l'avoir ensuite norris et qu'il
laisserait la peut prouver au dessus
donc l'affection bactériologique la
plastique tout petit comme ça lâche un
brevet sans nom
voilà l'homme là bas quand on attend une
heure pour voir de cette bourde l'add on
a pu le voir au long de la balade
beaucoup de beaucoup d'eau surtout les
versants nord pas forcément des sources
captée par tous et même là où il ya des
sources capter il ya toujours quand même
à proximité d'un petit risque chronique
va monter dans la source ou quoi que ce
soit quoi donc bon on s'arrange avec ce
que plutôt que de porter plein d'eau
aussi qu'on en trouvera dans les
ruisseaux
on garde quelques gourmands bourdais a
encore presque complète extrait pour ça
les gens vont pouvoir boire dedans
pendant l'heure où leur l'euro va être
traité
dans cette fleur
on a eu un petit souci d'aiguillage en
fait on est arrivé
ici et par défaut quand on sait qu'on
doit monter donc on s'est dit bon voilà
là ça monte donc on prend le côté là et
en fin de compte nan c'est pas du tout
ça je pense que sur la gauche vous êtes
monté non la raison on avait que 100 m
de dénivelé il reste 400 c'est ça je
passe des vertes et j'avoue que c'était
surtout après le repas la moi j'ai
commis une grosse erreur que j'avais pas
avant mais les autres j'ai demandé au
guide s'il faut accélérer un peu
maintenant d'accord donc une superbe
idée un peu les distorsions va dire mais
ça fait du bien un peu de se dépenser de
piquer un peu de points que d'habitude
dans mes amis le soir moi je pense qu'il
ya quelques uns qui soit un peu limite
yves endurance pour faire ça steven
aucoin s'appelle margerie est lancé
mireille franc c'est comme ça fred avec
son genou qui est handicapé et d'avoir
un peu de mal pour les autres ça a l'air
d'aller je pense
jérôme il arrive devant alors ils
montent au train peinard donc ça va se
passe bien
keaven m'a épaté je trouve qu'il est fin
j'ai eu l'impression qui sait dépasser
et c'est tout change ouais j'ai vu que
tout le monde attendait les derniers on
verra si j'ai la tige et là oh là aussi
avec nous
ici se passe absolument un de plus entre
gérard et moi qu'entre qu'avec les
autres participants non il fait que
gérard on a parlé pas mal parce que
gérard en fait je trouve à ce niveau là
il est vraiment ri bon déjà il est dans
le sport en athlétisme et l'art je
trouve que c'est très bien parce que
quand il ya quelqu'un qui est retardée à
l'arrière du groupe il demain il ay
pense mama a demandé aux autres
d'attendre la personne et comme
effectivement je suis assez souvent
l'arrière du groupe
il s'avère qu'il est assez souvent
attendu et puis on a eu l'occasion de
discuter un peu
c'est plus sympa que klaus s'est jamais
je veux dire aller tout seul derrière
c'est pas cool c'est mieux c'est plus
sympa d'être à plusieurs pour terminer
le parcours donc jeté leur cuir gt
devant pire était derrière
aujourd'hui enfin la ronde
alors vous avez vu assez un rocher est
complètement différent de ce qu'on a
plus parcourir et qui ne souriait le
début la rando on a dû égaler en fin de
compte de silice qui sont maçonné en
fait pas décoller qui les ont collé
c'est la nature qui a fait ça au fond de
la mer en fait quand il ya de nombreux
millions d'années il pas le jour où la
mère s'en va on se trouve une roche
sédimentaire cette fois ci alors qu'est
ce qui fait qu ici il en reste alors que
dans la montée y en a plus bas c'est
tout simplement parce qu'à un moment il
ya une ligne de fracture
donc c'est plus remplie degrés à cette
époque là quoi un des pôles de sa plus
important
et puis bah tout le tout le grec était
tout autour du massif il est parti il a
été érodée en voilà donc en à peu près
de 160 millions d'années ça laisse du
temps et ici comme j'en avais un peu
plus bas y est resté il a pas y aller un
petit peu qui reste et qui va aussi
finir par partir par s'éroder
thione terrienne dans quelques millions
d'années peut-être que le rocher saint
jacques qui n'existera plus bas donc on
espère et on est là on va au plateau on
est à 7 cm encore donc se creuse donc
cette vos 2 50 mètres à environ encore
donc la tourbière dans les vosges et se
forme à partir d'une plante tout à fait
caractéristique qu'on appelle la
sphaigne on avait déjà un peu parlé à la
semaine c'est cette boue ce
extraordinaire qui a tout simplement la
capacité de retenir près de 40 fois son
poids sec en nantes
c'est une éponge bonjour me l'avait fait
bonne route
il prévient pas de voiture
bonjour jérôme anglaise ou le formidable
qu'est ce que vous êtes bien situé avec
l'efficace à lui que vous demandez on va
juste une jamais nous amène au relais
robin 50 l'heure et l'endroit où on dort
et vu son cours plus bas
pour les volontaires donc on peut dormir
dans le foie on peut bien on le fit un
bon d'accord il y en a plusieurs hockey
et balle et on va aller chercher les
sacs et pour se laver
on se retourne salle de bains salle de
bain d'accord vous pouvez regarder un
petit peu ce soir au havre pour taper à
ma troisième jour un palais fallait
reconstituer les réserves donc le plat
de base du vosgien du cochon sous toutes
ses formes mais du fumé du lard et
d'associés et puis derrière les fameuses
tofaïe right of ice et un plat de pommes
vous dit pas comment j'ai fait il
voulait savoir alors ce n'est pas ta ta
l'étouffer cuite avec un peu de graisse
de porc malien alors ça avec ça
franchement de mal et monte sa sphère
bicyclette à sa fille si vous attaquez
le monde
c'est pas mon choix
je pensais que ça irait mal
non c'est moi qui ai fait la nes s'est
jeté sous tendent et anonyme
présentant à son jardinet
la jeanne d'arc j'y vois des gens
blessés
les céréales ce matin
hall a regardé ce qui nous arrive
voilà avec étiquette spéciale pour
l'occasion confiture de plus est la
grande randonnée le 20 août 2012
je rajoute ça donne des sacs à domicile
par eric delhaye sacré coup
je vous transmets de rien on ne peut
même pas moche est
quand même les beaux jeux fall massive
aux ja c'est vraiment une terre une
terre marque meurtri au niveau d'un des
conflits 1870 bien sûr 14-18 et puis
surtout voilà pour ce qui concerne ce
monument la 39 45
les vosges était vraiment une terre pour
les allemands hyper importante
il avait déjà perdu une bonne partie de
terrain et ils savaient que s'ils
perdaient le massif vosgien
après c'est la plaine d'alsace donc
c'était directement pour pour eux la
défaite est là l'entrée des troupes vers
l'allemagne ça s'est traduit par ben ils
ont effectivement attaqué tous les
maquis et puis surtout ils ont fait ce
qu'on appelle la têt la politique de la
terre brûlée dire qu'ils ont évacué tous
les civils et ils ont fait flamber les
maisons donc ça a été un vrai
traumatisme pour les gens qui vivaient
là 85 90 % de l'habitat détruits sur ses
valets là ça veut dire plus rien
derrière tous les plateaux qui était
encore en agriculture et à un petit
siècle sont devenus forestiers et les
gens se sont se sont comment retrouver
beaucoup plus beaucoup plus haut valais
je vous l'avais promis vous l'aurez donc
juste en face la petite butte verte bien
verte pétantes là bas c'est là qu'on va
descendre et on voit même pas jusqu'où
on va descendre puis un peu plus loin du
concubin on va on va manger en attendant
nous a fait voir le ch mâcon et qu'on
allait en pra très empruntée au loin une
belle montée maintenant je commence à
être rodé donc devrait bien se passer
rendrai mon rythme je dirais bien
alors vous allez bien gardé mais doit
normalement ça devrait marcher
ouf ok voilà s'il y en a qui veulent
essayer la chaussure sur ces ventres
charnue ça devrait fonctionner est resté
sur l'autre si bon c'est là je vous
rappelle on a on a fait une erreur
puisque sinon une invasive une plante
qu'on ne souhaiterait pas voir se
développer dans l'ébauché dollars donc
là maintenant on fait beaucoup pour les
autres graines à la maturité
et un peu à moi je m'en doutais un peu
steven avec des ampoules assez mal placé
sous le pied donc j'avais dit surtout de
regarder que les laisse taussac là le
confit de papa voilà là ils assortissent
était partie la défense est normal
justement leur poule et pas leur poule
et pas comment explosé et l'idée c'est
vraiment d'éviter qu'elle explose
pourquoi que derrière il ya en plus un
risque d'infection autre chose comme ça
quoi
donc là pour moi la priorité c'est faire
en sorte que ça ne s'empire pas voilà on
aura droit à une épilation gratuite au
niveau du pied partout dans les bras ah
non je vais très bien je botte combat
moi j'ai pas mal du tout même
donc tout va bien la remontée des
matières spéciales beau les consignes
avant là la petite montée alexandre oui
j'avais envie de moi oui donc ça va être
simple chemin on prend le chemin un gi
derrière
c'est la forêt tout le lot et un
balisage notez donc tu suis au tu vois
un premier champ de pâture une clairière
tu penses à ceux qui sont tout en bas
encore ouais voilà donc pour tous ceux
qui sont entre alexandre et moi qui
serai dernier parce que j'ai un peu de
mal donc c'est sam c'est bien balisée au
monde c'est dans la forêt c'est des tout
petits est ce vous avez vu sur la carte
ça monte assez raide
donc on attaque tranquille il ya à peu
près entre un peu plus de 400 m de
dénivelé
donc normalement une petite heure de
monter voilà un peu plus raide que hier
mais beaucoup plus court il ya davantage
allez zou
vous avez vu monter ses débuts
souvent ça me faire seulement
j'étais derrière alexandre j'étais juste
derrière mais il a entendu qu'avec mes
bâtons je pense qu'il a dû accélérer
parce que je voulais pas que je le
rattrape comme il ya un petit challenge
entre nous et mattia le voilà donc il a
dû subir les tests a fait avec ton sac
tu vas où la belge est en deçà de 15 ha
ok d'accord sur le voilà bien sûr
défendu quelques avait oublié fans son
sac pour monter steven pas moi non
franchement voilà écoute j'ai pas visé
quand il ya l'exemple qui nous a
rejoints pas très loin d'ici
pour demander qui si oui kaka voulait
que lui prête son sac
il m'a proposé mais j'ai voulu rester
fidèle à mon sac continuer être
courageux et arriver jusqu'au bout et
j'y suis arrivé
oui on a quoi été attaqués ici à c'est
d'ailleurs la zone où il ya le plus de
tact dans les vosges sur le col du
brabant dans les vosges le loup ces deux
temps de présence maintenant cette année
c'est 48 attaque ça en presque 150
bhutto de croquer quoi ouais donc une
vraie préoccupation pour pour les
éleveurs qu'on a vu passer là tout à
l'heure j'ai repéré des traces à deux
reprises donc à une fois que les gens il
ya un réseau qu'on appelle loup lynx qui
centralise toutes les informations
notamment cet hiver ils ont repéré un
loup ne réussisse à 40 km
voilà peut-être présentation je compte
sur vous pour me renvoyer plein de
choses et que ça soit riche en 7,7
secondes
allez zou c'est parti on te suit
d'abord ça le jeûne est à bâle et à
lorsqu'il a d'extraordinaire
le jeune et à banes qui va
extraordinaires ont fait des blessés la
lafleur lafleur et jaune elle est le
fruit cfc quoi ça ressemble à quoi
haricots haricots très bien et dedans
vous avez donc des petits pois et les
petits points quand ils sont secs ça va
donner quoi ça donne quoi les rejets ça
redonne ça redonnera pas dérogé à
belgrade est planté caen c'est à dire
des déjeuners à bail un formidable
voilà derrière évident et patrick asch
vous rappeler à la une à la deux un
droit en laine mes yeux je vous propose
de vous présenter yannick maître de
cérémonie pour ce soir
je vous présente les lis je vous
présente nos arbres hautes donc il ya un
gros sapin
je vous invitais a donc commencé juste
leur dire bonjour
chacun va choisir un arbre qui sert de
support
je te prends deux secondes dans ses bras
lui dire bonjour le caresser un taux si
vous avez envie
donc elle voulait juste bonjour à votre
manière chacun fait ce qu'il veut et eu
un petit mot doux ça lui fait plaisir ce
qu'ils vont nous héberger ses premiers
d'encaisser des forts soutiens les
maigres
ces gars là je veux pas dire mais elle
est douloureuse
c'est plutôt chaud merguez et saucisses
et là des patates de l'histoire des
véhicules vendus ça fait pas longtemps
qu'on l'a on avancer ce projet c'était
de se poser la question voulait dormir
dans les arbres c'est qu'est ce qu'on
fait on fait des cabanes au frangin
charpentier ont tendance à faire des
plans tout ça donc c'est dévoile avec
cabane c'est des tonnes de bois mort d
un arbre vivant là c'est vraiment dormir
près du tronc en étant vraiment en
osmose avec l'environnement qui autour
de mouy au niveau d'installations ne va
rien laisser dans les arbres dans
l'activité graal d'arbres com - voilà
faire ce soir
on installe en armes juste avec des
cordes on essaye de ne pas laisser de
traces sur la rue on connaissait un truc
ça reste trois quatre jours on laisse
reposer l'arbre en ans il revient à
notre une installation
et
les vosgiens
f